let me ask
the sexy hot thing on the presses right
now is gpt
3 got released with openai it's a latest
language model
they have kind of an api where you can
create a lot of fun applications
i think it's as people have
said it's probably more hype than
intelligent but there's a lot of really
cool
things ideas there with increasing size
you can have
better and better performance on
language what are your thoughts about
gbt3 in connection to your work with the
open domain
dialogue but in general like this
learning
in an unsupervised way from the internet
to generate one character at a time
creating
pretty cool text
so we partner up before for the api
launch so we started working with them
when
um they decided to put together this api
and we tried it without fine tuning that
we tried it with fine tuning on our data
and we work closely to actually optimize
this model for um
some of our data sets
it's kind of cool because i think we're
kind of we're this polygon polygon for
this kind of experimentation space for
experimental space for for these models
uh to see how they actually work
with people because there are no
products publicly available that do that
that focus on open domain conversations
so we can
you know test how facebook blends are
doing or how gpt3 doing
uh so with gpd3 we managed to improve by
a few percentage points like three
or four pretty meaningful amount of
percentage points our main metric which
is the
ratio of conversations that make people
feel better
and every other metric across across the
field got a little boost
right now i'd say one out of five
responses from replica comes from gpg3
wow so our own blender mixes up like a
bunch of candies from different
blender you said well yeah just the
model that looks at
looks at top candidates from different
models and picks the
most the best one uh so right now one of
five will come from
gp3 that's really great i mean uh
what's the do you have hope for like
do you think there's a ceiling to this
kind of approach so we've had for a very
long time
we've used um since the very beginning
we most it was
most of replica was scripted and then a
little bit of this fallback
part of replica was using a retrieval
model um
and then those retrieval models started
getting better and better and better
with transformers it got a lot better
and we're seeing great results and then
with gpd2
finally generative models that
originally were
not very good and were a very very
fallback option
for most of our conversations we
wouldn't even put them in production
finally we could use some generative
models as well along
um you know next to our retrieval models
and then now we do gpt3 they're almost
on par
um so that's pretty exciting i think
just seeing how
from the very beginning of um you know
from 2015 where the first model start
to pop up here and there like sequence
sequence
uh the first papers on that from my
observer standpoint
first no it's not you know doesn't
really is not really building it but
it's only testing it on people basically
in my product to see how all of a sudden
we can use generative
dialogue models in production and
they're better than others
and they're better than scripted content
so we can't really get
our scripted hard-coded content anymore
to be as good as our internet model
that's exciting they're much better
yeah to your question whether that's the
right
way to go i'm again i'm in the observer
seat i'm just
um watching this very exciting movie
um i mean so far it's been stupid to bet
against deep learning so whether
increasing the size size even more or
the 100
trillion parameters will finally get us
to the
right answer whether that's the way or
whether there should be
there has to be some other again i'm
definitely not an expert anyway i think
and that's purely my instinct saying
that there should be something else as
well
for memory uh for sure but the question
is
i wonder i mean yeah and then the
argument is for reasoning or for memory
it might emerge with more parameters
larger
but might emerge you know i would never
think that to be honest like
maybe in 2017 where we've been just
experimenting with all
you know with all the research that has
been coming that was coming out then
i felt like there's like we're hitting a
wall that there should be something
completely different
but then transformer models and then
just bigger models and then all of a
sudden size matters
at that point it felt like something
dramatic needs to happen
but it didn't and just the size you know
gave us these results that to me are you
know
clear indication that we can solve this
problem pretty soon did uh fine-tuning
help
quite a bit oh yeah without it we it
wasn't as good
i mean there is a compelling hope that
you don't have to do fine-tuning
which is one of the cool things about
gbt3 it seems to do well without any
fine-tuning
i guess for specific applications you
still want to train it on a certain
like add a little fine-tune on like a
specific use case but
um it's an incredibly impressive uh
thing from my standpoint and again i'm
not
an expert so i want to just say that
yeah there will be people there
yeah i have access to the api i've been
i'm going to probably do a bunch of fun
things with it
um i already did some fun things some
videos coming out
uh just for the hell of it i mean i
could be a troll at this point with it
i haven't used it for serious
applications so it's really cool to see
you're right you you are you're able to
actually use it with real people and see
how well it works that's really exciting
you